this ain't no bean potty last Friday I
had a burger for lunch and then a burger
for dinner
you're on desert island what food would
you have cheeseburger I haven't had any
like ground or land meat for like nine
years I have to be yesterday but are
some some murmurs notice that it's
pretty good I didn't give up meat
because it tastes bad so I still
wouldn't love a really solid substitue
and I've heard that this is it
[Music]
we say bleep I'm hoping that if this
burger is as advertised that I won't
have to eat meat anymore I'm expected to
be disappointed oh my god I'm pretty
excited about this right now
[Music]
if I didn't know better I would look at
this and think this is a burger it
actually smells like ground beef oh my
god it looks very juicy wha Wow too
[Music]
why yep tastes like a burger it's got a
char on it just like a burger it kind of
that like French that you sometimes miss
this can not be me this is impossible
it's really nice that you do have to
remind yourself you're eating a veggie
burger
there's lightyears ahead of any other
fake where have you close your eyes you
can taste it more and try not to make it
too much like a commercial just
overwhelmingly positive but really I
literally had a burger yesterday and
like this is just as good you ever have
those things that are so good like you
just want to concentrate on the moment
it looks like a real patty which is
crazy this is coming to an end and I'm
really sad about it if I were on a
desert island and I asked for
cheeseburgers for the rest of my life
and they gave me this I wouldn't be mad
at it it also makes me feel good that
like eating something like this is doing
good for the environment if this is the
future of meatless meats then I'm on
board
ladies and gentlemen s finger looking
good this is me becoming a vegetarian
you heard it here first
Wow